a show of solidarity as moldova calls
for international support the u.s
secretary of state is visiting one of
europe's poorest and smallest countries
that shares a border with ukraine in the
30 years since moldova and the united
states began diplomatic relations
we've never faced a moment as urgent and
as challenging as the one that we face
today
russia's unprovoked
unwarranted war
on ukraine
has kicked off a humanitarian crisis
that is already having a vast effect
across the region including here in the
republic of moldova
moldova didn't choose to be involved but
these are the implications of a war on
its doorstep
nearly a quarter of a million people
have crossed its border from ukraine in
just 10 days the second largest number
of refugees after poland
moldova warns it's fast running out of
options to keep up with the influx which
is expected to rise in the coming days
only through joint and consistent
efforts from all the partners we can
help out ukraine first of all we need
rapid assistance and involvement of the
international community to stop the
battle and restore the peace
the international monetary fund is
considering moldova's request to make
changes to its existing imf supported
programmes to help the refugees but
moldova's concerns don't stop there it
faces a security threat on its eastern
border russian-backed separatists
control the region of transnistria
the disputed territory has its own
government currency and around 6 000
paratroopers since it fought a bitter
civil war with moldova in 1992 but it
isn't recognized internationally and
russia has repeatedly ignored calls to
remove around 1 500 of its troops who've
been stationed there ever since the area
also has what is thought to be one of
the biggest ammunition depots in eastern
europe there is a fundamental
disagreement between moldovans and
transnistrian leadership and this is the
path the development path that they want
to choose moldova
always declared that it wanted to
integrate economically with europe
and that's why it was seeking membership
with the european union
and
transnistria was seeking alignment
with russia
alignments made clearer on thursday when
moldova and georgia followed ukraine's
footsteps and applied to join the
european union a process in the making
for years that fast-tracked in just a
matter of days
al jazeera
anthony lincoln's also saying the us may
send planes to poland to backfill
warsaw's numbers if the polish
government sends some of its own planes
to help ukraine
we are
we're looking actively now
at the question of airplanes that poland
may provide to uh to ukraine and looking
at how we might be able to backfill
should poland decide to produce those to
supply those planes
can't speak to a timeline but i can just
tell you we're looking at it very very
actively
russia has warned countries against
hosting ukrainian military aircraft the
defense military says they'd be regarded
as being involved in the conflict
earlier president vladimir putin says
the invasion will only be halted if
ukraine stops what he calls its
hostilities he's blamed the kiev
government for the fighting
frank ludwig is a senior lecturer in
military capabilities and strategy at
the university of portsmouth he's also a
former military officer who served in
the balkans in iraq and afghanistan he
says the russian campaign in ukraine
appears to be lacking in preparation and
planning
well i think most analysts people like
myself take the view that the ukrainians
are coming up to prove
we expected them to be effective they've
been ready for this for years they've
been trained by western forces and if
you look at the way their regular forces
look the way they present themselves
they present themselves very much like
nato forces like british america french
or german troops professional
well-equipped and so forth
what's really shocking though is the way
the russian forces have essentially i
use this word hesitatingly collapsed
over the last 10 days or so the much
wanted combined arms operations force
that learned so much from their
conflicts over the last few years
it's proving to be a bit of a paper
tiger at the moment but nonetheless that
paper tiger is going to turn into
something that's really deadly for the
people of of of ukraine it's a failure
of planning of preparation and logistics
it's very clear that those troops from
from we see this from capture pow
accounts we see this from
fairly objective reports the troops
weren't ready for what's going to happen
they were not briefed properly weren't
prepared their logistics which is the
which is the most important element of
military operations professionals taught
logistics amateurs talk tactics and the
russians have failed in their logistics
here
and they failed largely i think because
they overestimated their own
capabilities and underestimated the
ukrainians and particularly with respect
to their own capabilities they failed to
deal with the trivia with what you and i
many people might regard as trivia
fueling food
general supplies what routes are you
going to take
how are you going to space your vehicles
how are you going to echelon your attack
that's how you're going to organize and
arrange your attack
and this all speaks to a real lack of
preparation and a real lack of planning
and that's the most difficult part of a
military operation is getting things
right early getting things right
well in time for your operations it's
very clear the russians haven't done
that